digamos que tenemos la función game es
igual a la secante pero no nos vamos a
tomar la secante de x vamos a tomarnos
la secante de tres primeros esto menos x
y lo que queremos es averiguar cuánto
vale la derivada de james con respecto a
x en x igual
y bueno hagamos x igual a pi cuartos y
como siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes averiguarlo por tu cuenta bien
como puedes ver aquí tenemos una función
compuesta estamos sacando la secante no
sólo de x sino de una función de esta
expresión que tenemos aquí así que por
ejemplo si ustedes llaman a esto que
tenemos aquí de x pongamos el nombre
de x vamos a notarlo por aquí de x va a
ser igual a 3 y medios 3 pig medios
menos x y bueno si tenemos un x podemos
ver cuánto vale prima de x y esto va a
ser igual a la derivada de tres primeros
bueno
la derivada constante 0 se elimina y
después la derivada de menos x lo cual
es menos 1 y bueno esto lo puedes ver
como una regla de las potencias esto es
lo mismo que aquí tenemos como exponente
a 1 lo bajamos y me queda menos 1 que
multiplican a x elevado a la potencia
uno menos uno es decir a la potencia
cero pero x elevado la potencia cero es
1 por lo tanto simplemente me quedan
menos 1 así que podríamos ver esto como
la derivada de la secante con respecto a
de x
por la derivada de de x con respecto a x
y podrías decir bueno que hay con la
derivada de la secante y bueno en otros
vídeos lo que hicimos fue obtener esa
derivada de hecho podría volver a
derivar lo secante de x es simplemente 1
/ coseno de x y así que la derivada sale
directamente de la regla de la cadena de
todas maneras voy a escribirlo en otros
vídeos probamos que la derivada con
respecto a x de esta función secante de
x esto era exactamente igual que el seno
de x el seno de x entre el coseno
cuadrado de
de lujo así que si estamos tratando de
encontrar la derivada de james con
respecto a x va a ser igual a la
derivada de la secante con respecto a
por la derivada de con respecto a x así
que vamos a hacerlo la derivada de james
con respecto a x esto va a ser igual a
la derivada de la secante con respecto a
1 y bueno tenemos la derivada de la secc
ante esto es lo mismo que el seno
de la función de x déjame poner la sim
de x a bien podrías poner aquí la
función de x la función de x que es esta
que tengo aquí pero lo voy a hacer de
esta manera para que sea todo mucho más
claro para ti esto dividido entre el
coche en un cuadrado de esta función de
x dejar en poner otra vez aquí de x ok y
a esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de la derivada de 1 con
respecto a x entonces tenemos la
derivada de la secante con respecto a de
x y luego la regla de la cadena nos dice
que esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de un con respecto a
esta derivada y aquí va a ser igual esto
bueno pues simplemente podemos sustituir
bueno pues esto va a ser igual a y
tenemos el seno de esta función de x que
ahora voy a escribir 3
medios - x ok
esto entre
el coche no cuadrado el coseno cuadrados
de esta misma función déjame ponerlo de
nuevo tres y medios menos x
ok y a todo esto hay que multiplicarlo
por un prima de x que ya vimos que es
menos uno también puede haber puesto el
signo negativo aquí pero lo voy a hacer
en el siguiente paso para que todo quede
mucho más claro ahora lo importante es
que quiero encontrar estas derivadas
cuando me x vale y cuartos así que en
lugar de x voy a poner mi cuartos pi
cuartos y aquí también voy a poner pin
cuartos
así que cuánto va a ser esto bueno esto
va a ser igual
el seno el seno y ahora cuánto es tres
primeros menos pi cuartos bueno eso lo
puedo hacer aquí tres primeros tres
primeros es lo mismo que seis cuartos si
sacamos un denominador común menos y
cuartos menos mil cuartos esto es lo
mismo que cinco cuartos de lujo entonces
me quedan el seno de cinco
fin
cuartos ok
esto dividido a su vez entre el coseno
cuadrado de lo mismo 5 p cuartos así que
lo voy a poner aquí
5 cuartos de lujo y todo esto por menos
1 así que en lugar de poner aquí por
menos 1 voy a poner un signo negativo
por acá ahora cuánto es el seno de 5
cuartos y el coseno de 5 cuartos bien
realmente no lo sé de memoria pero de
hecho podemos dibujar por aquí un
círculo unitario y recordar cuánto es
eso así que déjame hacerlo por aquí voy
a dibujar un círculo ok y deberíamos ser
capaces de encontrar cuánto vale cada
uno de estos entonces en un círculo
unitario tenemos los siguientes ángulos
y déjenme recordarlo porque mi cerebro a
veces convierte todo a grados y cuarto
se es lo mismo que 45 grados así que
aquí tengo y cuartos por aquí tengo 2
cuartos por aquí tres cuartos por aquí
tengo cuatro cuartos y por aquí tengo
cinco cuartos aterrizamos justo ahí así
que si quieren ver dónde intersectan el
círculo unitario esto está en el punto
está en el punto menos raíz de 2 sobre 2
coman menos raíz de 2 sobre 2
y bueno si quieres saber cómo supe esto
te invito a revisar el círculo unitario
de algunos de los ángulos estándar
alrededor del círculo unitario y eso lo
puedes encontrar en la sección de
trigonometría de la canaca deming pero
esto es suficiente para nosotros ya que
sabemos que el seno es la coordenada
james que en este caso es menos la raíz
de 2 sobre 2 entonces en lugar de esto
voy a poner menos la raíz de 2 sobre 2 y
el coste no es la coordenada x de este
punto es decir también menos la raíz de
2 sobre 2 pero ojo está elevado al
cuadrado así que aquí me quedaría menos
la raíz de 2 sobre 2
esto elevado al cuadrado ok y no
olvidemos este signo negativo este signo
negativo que tenemos aquí y entonces
esto va a ser igual este signo negativo
por este signo negativo se convierte en
positivo me queda la raíz de 2 sobre 2
ya esto lo voy a dividir ya que tengo
bueno este negativo se convierte en
positivo la raíz de 2 elevado al
cuadrado eso es lo mismo que 2 de abajo
me quedarían 4 así que esto de aquí es
lo mismo que dos cuartos que es lo mismo
que un medio lo voy a poner aquí
y ahora nos merecemos un poco de redoble
de tambor porque estamos llegando al
resultado que queremos es lo mismo que
raíz de 2 sobre 2 que multiplica a 2
dividir por un medio es lo mismo que
multiplicar por su recíproco y ahora
estos dos se cancelan y me quedan
simplemente la raíz de dos y ya está
este es el resultado que estábamos
buscando la pendiente de la recta
tangente para la gráfica de james cuando
x es igual a pi cuartos es de raíz de 2
muy emocionante